>> Tucker: FOR MONTHS, AND
OPRAH WINFREY PRESIDENTIAL RUN
THANKS TO DONALD TRUMP, THE AGE
OF THE CELEBRITIES POLITICIAN
MAY BE UPON US AND STAY HERE.
MARK STEYN IS AN AUTHOR AND
COLUMNIST AND HE JOINS US
TONIGHT.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR AT THE OUTSET
AND ON THE RECORD THAT I AM NOT
IN ANY WAY CRITICIZING OPRAH.
I THINK IT'S A FEDERAL CRIME,
SO I'M NOT DOING THAT NOW.
BUT I'M WONDERING WHAT YOU MADE
OF THE REACTION TO OPRAH WINFREY
LAST NIGHT WERE YOU HAD PEOPLE,
EVEN REPUBLICANS, PURPORTEDLY
BILL KRISTOL JUMPING IN AND
SAYING RUN OPRAH.
WHAT IS THAT?
>> I THINK BILL KRISTOL, IF YOU
SUPPORTS THE DEEP STATE AGAINST
TRUMP, I THINK WE SHOULD DRAW
FROM BILL KRISTOL SUPPORT OF
OPRAH'S CANDIDACY THAT SHE HAS
BEEN AN AGENT OF THE DEEP STENT
FOR MANY YEARS.
THAT'S WHY BILL KRISTOL SUPPORTS
SURPRISE ME GIVEN THE CONTROL
SHE SEEMS TO HAVE OVER PEOPLE'S
MINDS.
I THINK WE'RE BOTH ASSUMING THAT
IF SHE RAN THE DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY SHE WOULD GET THE
NOMINATION, RIGHT?
AND WENDY ACKNOWLEDGED THIS IN A
TO DRAG BILL de BLASIO OR
ELIZABETH WARREN OR BERNIE OVER
THE FINISH LINE, OR DO YOU JUST
WANT TO CUT TO THE CHASE AND GO
WITH OPRAH?
THEY ARE BETTING THAT IF IT'S
WHAT HE DID TO JEFF AND HILLARY.
AND IN A SENSE, THAT'S VALID.
SHE WAS BY FAR THE LEAST IDIOTIC
PERSON AT THAT AWARD CEREMONY
LAST NIGHT.
SHE WAS CRAFTY AND CUNNING IN
THE WAY SHE TIED HER PERSONAL
STORY TO THIS #MeToo BUSINESS.
WHICH I THINK IS ACTUALLY ONE OF
ROSANNA ARQUETTE AND MIRA
HAVE BEEN SEXUALLY ABUSED BY
THESE MUSLIM GROOMING GANGS AND
THEN WATCHED AS ALL THESE
OPPORTUNIST ACTIVISTS AND
POLITICIANS TURNED THE SCANDAL
INTO A WAY TO ADVANCE THEMSELVES
UP THE GREASY POLL, AND THE
VICTIMS WERE IGNORED.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED
LAST NIGHT.
MIRA AND ROSANNA AND ROSE
McGOWAN DIDN'T GET ANY INVITES
TO THE GOLDEN GLOBES.
IF ALL THESE RIDICULOUS A
HOW MUCH I SUPPORT DEFENSELESS
WOMEN BY ONLY WEARING BLACK.
I'VE ORDERED MY COUTURIER TO
DRESS ME LIKE AUDREY HEPBURN AND
BREAKFAST AT TIFFANY'S.
THAT WILL SHOW THEM.
AND IT WAS COMPLETELY
PREPOSTEROUS.
AND OPRAH ACTUALLY -- OPRAH, WHO
WAS MORE OPPORTUNIST THAN ANY OF
THEM, ACTUALLY SEES THAT ISSUE
AND APPROPRIATED IT TO HERSELF,
WHICH I WOULD BE ANNOYED ABOUT
IF I WERE MIRA SORVINO, BUT SHE
DID IT AT A SKILL LEVEL THAT IS
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.
AND SHE CERTAINLY IS A BRILLIANT
COMMUNICATOR.
SOMEONE SAID TO ME THOUGH
DOESN'T WANT TO BE CHARGED WITH
A CRIME EITHER, I RESPECT OPRAH,
BUT SOMETIMES THERE IS -- THIS
MAN SAID TO ME I FEEL LIKE SHE
DOESN'T LIKE ME.
SHE DOESN'T LIKE ME.
TO THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE FEEL
THAT WAY?
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
POPULATION FEELS LIKE OPRAH IS
ON THEIR SIDE?
>> THE QUESTION IS WHETHER OPRAH
IS ON OUR SIDE.
SHE GAVE A RATHER SERIOUS
INTERVIEW, I THINK IT WAS TO THE
BBC A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO, WHERE
SHE SAID THAT IT REALLY JUST OLD
WHITE PEOPLE NEED TO DIE.
AND THIS IS WHERE IT GETS TO
WENDY'S THING ABOUT HOW SHE
HEALS US ALL AND SHE BRINGS US
ALL TOGETHER.
I'M NOT ACTUALLY SURE AT THIS
THAT.
TODAY, NOT JUST BECAUSE AMERICA
HAS ELECTED A BLACK PRESIDENT
AND THE GOLDEN GLOBES IS FULL OF
FAMOUS AND PROMINENT BLACK
CELEBRITIES, AND INDEED A
BIRACIAL AMERICAN WOMAN IS ABOUT
BUT HER MAJESTY THE QUEEN, WHO
HAS TO APPROVE EVERY MOYLE MIKE
ROYAL MARRIAGE DOESN'T EITHER.
THERE'S SOMETHING SLIGHTLY WEIRD
IN HER ATTEMPT, WHICH WAS
EFFECTIVE WITH THE CROWD, AND
THE #MeToo THING.
LET'S NOT FORGET, BY THE WAY,
THAT ALL THESE FEEL-GOOD MOVIES
WEINSTEIN, HARVEY WEINSTEIN
WANTED A PIECE OF ALL OF THOSE
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION FEEL-GOOD
BOOSTER MOVIES BECAUSE IT WAS A
GREAT WAY TO GET CHICKS, LIBERAL
THERE WERE ALL KINDS OF
CONTRADICTIONS AT PLAY IN THE
PATH SHE'S TRYING TO NEGOTIATE
THERE.
>> Tucker: EVERYTHING IS MARK
OBLIGATED THAN IT LOOKS.
MARK STEYN, THANK YOU FOR BEING
A SURE BUT THAT TWISTED PATH.